one of the lessons that the country
learned from the 911 attacks was that
even in a moment of great tragedy even
in a moment of great difficulty people
were able to come together as Americans
when we were challenged when we were
assaulted we were able to turn to each
other and ask for help the fact that we
were able to do that we were able to
come together is one of the greatest
Testaments to what it means to be an
American when historians look back what
they're going to see is that there was a
generation that emerged that volunteered
to be of service in some of the most
difficult and dangerous environments
we'd ever been presented with this was a
generation that really worked with the
courage of perseverance it was patients
that allowed the victories that
eventually came about in Iraq it was
patients that eventually allowed us to
capture Osama bin Laden what's uncertain
yet but what we need to see is that when
this generation comes home that they
come home to actually make our
communities stronger that fight is still
up in the air and that's a fight that we
still need to win we have to live for
something larger than ourselves we all
have to find a way in our own lives to
be of service to others around us and
when we do that we become stronger and
we build a stronger country together